i haven't mentioned this gentleman for a
while but i do need to discuss him
tonight we have an associate producer
you may know him
he's on our show and his name is jordan
schlansky
yeah we'll insert some booing there
anyway
uh for as long as i can remember
jordan's office
has been an embarrassing mess well
earlier this year just before our studio
was shut down by the kovid 19 pandemic i
mean
literally like two weeks before i called
in some big names to tackle a renovation
of jordan's
office okay we were gonna make this a
great remote
we brought a camera crew we even
screened what we shot for an audience
back in march literally one of the last
audiences we had
before kovid shut us down then
the lockdown hit and we had to delay
completing
jordan's office renovation until now
as you know uh i work with a guy named
jordan slansky who is a terrible slob
just a pig his office is a mess i've
tried many times to clean it up
and it's dirty again immediately i'm
sick of it i give up
that's why i brought in the big guns
the property brothers and we're glad to
be here i mean history shows
his employer how much you care about him
oh no i uh i'm happy if he dies tomorrow
hello have you met the uh property
no no brothers no usually i stand
when uh people come into the room and i
greet them i think that's more polite
would you like to stand i'm comfortable
the way i am
we've offered to do this for free to
help you and this is taking up a fair
bit of our time because
i mean look at the space this is a lot
to tackle i mean we're here to actually
add some features that really make this
the pimped out space that you would like
to have
i don't want to put anything in here i
didn't initiate this whole practice at
all
let's put this politely i'm not asking
you
i'm telling you we're going to clean up
this space
because you represent conan and i am
known for class
i am known for aesthetics i'm known
for a high level of design look you
gentlemen clearly have an agenda i'm
going to remain passive in this
situation
uh why don't you proceed to do what uh
you intend we're giving you
we're giving you an office is that what
you say before you're molested
god say you'd last long in prison well
you gentlemen have an agenda
i will remain passive and you do as you
please
what's a couple things about yourself
that would help us understand
what's important what are your interests
i'm a deep thinker
i explore
as well let me help you you love italy
do you not i do
i got married in italy so i mean i know
italy very well when you say you got
married in italy
therefore you know italy very well are
those two things necessarily connected
you're weird um i i did my research
what about something very cool like i
don't know like a pasta station
yes a food area where they would be
making you fresh pasta in your office
would you like that
the problem with eating carbohydrates on
their own without protein fat and fiber
to balance them out
is that it creates a splank in blood
sugar then the pancreas secretes insulin
to remove the sugar from the blood that
sugar is stored as fat the body is a
very efficient mechanism and you don't
want to waste that energy so you don't
like italy
personal grooming is very important you
like to shave the body shape
i respect the human body that we've all
been given and i like to present it and
it's best possible
well you know what uh we share some
traits i take care yes i mean i have
lasers
no hair let me see you actually shave
your body lasers i landed it
i believe in just having regular
do you remove the hair from your chest
uh i lasered twice
yeah it doesn't seem consistent with the
the hair on your legs no
in fact all three of us have modified
our body here
in this scenario you're the odd man now
i believe in letting it grow
uh it looks like a a copper brillo pad
beneath my belt and that's my way of
going because i've been in a very very
long marriage
and um well i think enough said
why do you have o mg
why do you have this here this is a
toilet stool it
ensures proper orientation of the pubo
rectalis muscle which is the muscle that
maintains
continence so this is like a squatty
potty knock off
no this is a uh squatty potty this is
their luxurious model it's made of
bamboo as opposed to a lower clock
quality plastic
why is it still in the box uh i haven't
unpacked and assembled it yet
i have a feeling he uses it and then
puts it back in the box it's the only
thing that's organized in this office
hold on a second
why do you have two of them why do you
have two
hey you dropped people in the subway and
say how about a little side-by-side
pooping
what about a toilet could we put a
toilet in this space
so that he could he might literally
never leave would you be willing to
uh evacuate your bowels in here if there
was a toilet uh i don't do that in the
workplace
how do you you save it up for all day
like you save up for 10 hours
my body's on a natural rhythm i've taken
great
steps to ensure the uh natural digestive
rhythm with my body
are you being serious you don't uh
defecate at work
you can't control your bodily functions
but you can't walk he loses it it's
great no
it's not when he the way he laughs his
eyebrows get so crazy
no i don't need to come to the workplace
and evacuate my bowel go you have to go
i don't have to go so you have never
pooped at work no that's insane
that's crazy how do you plan that out my
body follows a natural
rhythm it's almost circadian i'm
surprised that you are caught unaware so
often
do you defecate at work jordan all
people
eventually first of all i'm a celebrity
and as they will tell you
we just don't defecate at all but you
as a person everyone does how many times
a week would you say you defecate at
work
well i think you're talking about a very
this is a disgusting topic well i didn't
initiate the topic you're the one that
introduced the topic by having not one
but two
bamboo squatty potties so before the
show
is when you'll normally evacuate your
bowels if you need to i've done it
during the show
uh back that's why we had a desk and one
of the investors in the film came to
council bless iowa help
us make the movie uh which
consisted of him in a book building suit
in a cornfield would you evacuate your
balance here in the privacy of your own
room if we had
sort of like a prison toilet here i
wouldn't evacuate my bowels in this
workplace
whether there was or was not a toilet in
this house i will not eat green eggs in
hand
i will not defecate sam i am decorative
elements do you have any thoughts
yeah i mean if you want this to really
embrace your passion for italy
maybe like a like a marble statue or
something like that that'd be fantastic
uh no i don't see the value in that
well then that would be a yes
[Music]
[Applause]
and that that is the size conan
conan came in early and measured it out
actually
i'd be happy with that i mean it's
pretty nice eh
jordan congratulations and now do the
thing other humans do which is thank
uh jonathan and drew for their help
thank you pleasure
thank you look forward to seeing your
face when we're all done okay
normally this is where we'd show you our
3d computer animation
and talk about how the renovation would
proceed yeah but our big plans for
jordan's office that went out the window
and the pandemic hit
in fact since conan's warner brothers
studio closed down
and was abandoned by humans over five
months ago jordan's office was turned
into a breeding ground for rats
raccoons and the nine-banded armadillo
as a result jordan's office has been
condemned by the city of burbank
which forced us to rethink our
renovations first we're going to return
jordan to his office then reimagine the
entryway
by sealing it up with beautiful
reclaimed bricks imported from tuscany
giving jordan's final resting place the
italian style and look he craves
so jordan will be sealed off from all
human contact
and run out of oxygen pretty quickly is
that right um
two hours tops fantastic
oh my god this is exactly what i dreamed
it would be
i'm not sure about jordan but conan
seems pretty happy about the outcome
he does oh actually conan is something
we're extremely happy about it's the
brother versus brother premiere on hgtv
very smooth segway that's right thanks
conan